it's the most magical time I love
Halloween because it's the perfect
excuse to watch gut churning Liguria
movies and shows
now wait a minute something's wrong
something terribly wrong but great
Peckinpah's ghost
this is terrified not the show the
besmirching of a grand tradition
how can anyone enjoy these zombie
mutilations when the blood is so clearly
computer-generated authentic movie blood
is made of Karo syrup and red food
coloring on set
Laura Meister HG Lewis news kaopectate
blood into squids balloons connected to
little explosives I rigged up elaborate
pneumatic systems so blood would spray
and splatter properly but nowadays real
genuine authentic fake gore is falling
into this
you can't add Oprah violence in post
I get it Hollywood it's easier you don't
have to keep getting new squibs and
clean clothes for each retailer you can
fine-tune the explicitness to appease
the demands of ratings agencies give me
practical effects or give me death
states would maybe fail but using it as
realism the actors convey real fear
humans respond to the sight of the red
red cruelly the same way that a bold
response to a toreador escape and when a
tiny explosive opens up the squib and
actor knows that's the precise moment
that their characters been shot and they
can crumple or recoil properly maybe all
of this CG is why pop culture vampires
aren't scary and they add in all the
digital blood and fangs along with the
sparkly skin post-production if you can
turn a rock company into a hunky vampire
movie in post you're committing a crime
against humanity also why does blood
erupt like Old Faithful
from the noggin of a Walking Dead zombie
I'd assumed the undead would have pretty
low blood pressure but apparently it's
off the charts now who wants a can
what's your favorite movie blood spray
kurosawa-san Jareau Tarantino's Kill
Bill 1 let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel